on today's show we're gonna talk to a
married mother of two
who just doesn't know if she wants to be
married anymore we're gonna talk to a
young man
who is struggling because visiting
family is boring and awkward
and he wanted my opinion whoo and he got
it
and we're going to talk to a young woman
who just started a new job in the
pandemic hit
and she is struggling with the chief
demon of our time loneliness
stay with us
hey what up what up this is john and
this is the dr john colony show
it's a live show where we show up and
walk alongside
you and your friends and your family
people who are trying to figure out life
and learn how to be human beings
again we don't even know what that means
anymore but we're figuring it out
together
i'm still learning we talk about
everything on this show
right no matter what's going on in your
heart in your head and your family and
your country
so many people are just like you i know
you feel like a snowflake i know you
feel like you're the only one having
these thoughts you're not
we all are and so we're gonna talk about
it we talk about everything right
infidelity um holiday nonsense
politics i don't care what it is bring
it on let's do it let's figure it out
together
and sometimes on this show actually it's
becoming a more and more of
a theme that i want to inject into this
thing is positivity
positivity i get so many emails from all
over the world literally or
the i don't know what you call them the
dms the direct messages
on the instagrams whatever it is people
telling me hey i was listening to your
podcast last night i
just think it's the greatest thing ever
i was crying and crying
and part of me loves that and then part
of me thinks
man i don't want to be the cry guy but
some of these calls are so hard
right and so then i've got to figure out
ways to inject joy into this
um unlike my friend will back here he's
in the booth just guest watching
it's a little bit a little bit i'll be
watching
you a little bit creepy but he's back
there just checking us out and he was
here for
literally three minutes and he already
was violating
all of the booth codes so will i hope
you're having fun in there
sucker so i'm gonna i'm gonna do the
opposite of what will did was he came in
here for just a second
and injected poison all over the place
and i'm gonna inject some
joy this email comes from nikki pendley
she says hey dr d i wanted to let you
know that my
dad is a rock star awesome
i'm 40 years old and he's been an
amazing part of my life since i was born
i know that my dad's parents divorced
when he was a teenager and when i was a
kid he
we always had to navigate visits with
his mom or his dad carefully
as a teenager i found out that when he
was young his dad was physically abusive
to him and his siblings
i heard from my aunt that he was beaten
sometimes to the point where he
wouldn't lift his face off the ground
that's this was a big part of the reason
his parents divorced
my dad made it his mission in life to
end
the chain of abuse he and my mom had
four kids
moved across the country and they did
their best to raise us they took us to
church they did homework with us they
supported us in our interests
my dad was never the disciplinarian my
mom took over that role because dad
didn't feel like he had a filter to stop
himself when he was angry
he focused on loving us when i was going
through my teenage angst and friend
troubles he would come wake me up on
saturday mornings with a foot rub
he made me pancakes and wanted to know
everything that was going on in my life
as a mom of my own kids now i can't
imagine what that must have been like
for him
he is truly a hero who didn't fall into
the same trap he was born into and i'm
so grateful to have him in my life
nikki pendley thank you so much for
sending this note in
and to your dad when you have no model
when you don't know what a good dad
looks like because your dad
sucked when your dad beats you up
literally
and you just have to figure it out and
you know i don't know what good
parenting looks like
but it doesn't look like that and so i'm
even going to take myself out of the
equation
that's not always the best solution but
man in this
this situation it worked and they had a
wife that helped balance them out
that means they must have talked about
things communicated with one another
and then he just leaned in and said i
don't know what i'm going to do next but
i'm going to be present
and pancakes right james nikki's dad was
already regulating with breakfast back
in the day these suckers making fun of
me all over the world you and your
breakfast telling me well this dad did
it and it worked that's all i'm saying
nikki thank you for sending this in your
dad's truly is a hero who didn't fall
into the same trap he was born into
and we are all grateful that he's there
so whatever's going on in your heart
mind good stuff tough stuff bad stuff
give me a call
at one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one or you can go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and we will see
about having you on the show
quick little note i feel like such an
idiot doing this um
because i'm just not this guy i didn't
get into this business
this radio show thing to be this guy
but i just want to let everybody know
how grateful i am
i was sitting on a plot of land in
nowhere texas
over the thanksgiving holiday and i got
a text message from
my supervisor jeremy and jeremy
said hey check your email it's pretty
awesome so i thought he's playing a
trick on me
and i opened my email it turns out this
little book
that i wrote called redefining anxiety
it's just taking another look
letting people know you're not broken
you don't have a medical illness you
don't have a genetic disposition that's
going to end your life
there's another way to look at anxiety
that's much more freeing
much more optimistic much more hopeful
it's a tiny little thing it's a pamphlet
it's like
70 or 80 pages but it
it came out at number two on the
bestseller list an adult nonfiction i
didn't know what to say i thought they
were messing with me at first and
then we dug into it and then dave ramsey
sent me a note
it's been a really cool thing and here's
the thing we didn't promote it it wasn't
supposed to
do what it's doing um and so all the
things goes to you good folks who are
listening to this
show looking for new ways to approach
your families
looking for new ways to approach your
life so man i just i don't know what to
say and for those of you who listen to
this
show and know golly dude you talk too
much you know it's a big deal when i
tell you i'm speechless but i am
and i'm just grateful so thank you i'm
not going to talk about it anymore
i just want to say thanks to everybody
listening that's really cool all right
let's go to dawn in chicago
illinois dawn good morning how are we
doing
good morning john how are you i'm doing
so so good
how's it going and what can you do to
help
well um i've i've kind of got an
incident i don't know um okay
yeah my husband has been um
he's made some purchases without my full
knowledge or blessing
some big some small after these
purchases he either
lies about them the price about price of
them
will not totally fill me in or discuss
how
we paid or are paying um
or or just how things are being handled
um
so give me an example of something he's
bought that was too much
that was a violation of your trust
he um him and his brother had
bought a brand new tractor
i totally i still to this day don't even
know the full
amount of it i know that he's making
payments to his brothers
um that's always a good idea and by
always i mean
never a good idea to owe your brother
money
um so i've been trying to find a tractor
for my little place
and i can tell you this he probably
spent somewhere in the neighborhood of a
bajillion dollars
yeah because tractors cost more than
rocket ships evidently
they are super expensive so yeah
so we'll just make up a number but and
it's just big but
the bigger deal here is the besides the
money is he's lying to you and he's
being deceptive
right he's not telling you the truth and
so
anytime somebody comes to me with this
sort of question my first question
is to you are you a safe place for him
and what i mean by that is are you
somebody that you all sit down and you
talk about purchases you talk about
dreams you talk about big things
together
and you are somebody who
has your own vision and that vision is
going to come true no matter what
you're somebody who nags him to death
you're somebody who's always poking at
him
and he's just had to create an alt
universe just to
get through his day or are you a really
safe place you talk about things if he
would just talk to you about it and
you're finding out we call it financial
infidelity around here
but he's cheating on you with his money
right or with y'all's money
so which one of those are you um
i would say in the beginning and for a
while
uh we always talked and sat down um
and mapped out everything um
so what happened what happened where
that quit happening
um i finally kind of spoke up
about him buying things
like very impulse
and um he was
kind of always on me about buying you
know a shirt
or something here or there for our kids
or you know that kind of stuff
and then he would go and buy a gun
you know and not tell me about it or he
would make up this big
elaborate like thing about oh it was
such a great deal
sure and i think that i probably
got on the nag wagon and um
was trying to put my foot down with it
right so
at the end of the day we could talk
about this for
probably several hours my guess is
there's
other things here that if you were to
dig into
deeper than the money does he tell you
the truth about everything or is it
only money that he's shady about
um i think there's other things that
he's cheating about and
do you get on to him about just
money or do you have a very particular
way you like the house do you have a
very particular way you like
the way your business is run the way the
kids are taken care of
um and what i'm getting at here is are
you guys roommates or y'all partners
uh roommates okay
do you want to stay married to this guy
that's where i'm i'm stuck i don't i
don't know i do
you didn't answer my question you'd
answer my question do you want to stay
married to this guy
no okay have you ever said that out loud
before
no how long have you how long how loud
anybody
how long have you been married uh 13
almost 14 years do you have any little
ones
we have two how old are they a six and a
nine year old
okay when you just said out loud for the
first time to somebody
i don't know if i want to be married to
this guy anymore did you feel a sense of
panic or a sense of relief
panic okay
so here's what you got to do today all
right
because i know you called me about money
and your husband's spending
that almost never ever happens in a
vacuum
right it almost never you've got this
great couple who is
in partnership with everything and by
the way
right um he just lies about money
that's just usually not how that works
yeah
and so today i know you called me about
money this is a bigger deal than that
today i need you to get with a friend
that you trust
and i need you to be totally honest with
your friend
i need you to tell your friend i need
you to sit there and listen to me and
it's going to be best to not
be a family member and i want you to
walk through
how you feel what's been happening
and be honest what have you contributed
to this
right because it's easier to get with a
friend and just blame him for everything
but that's probably not all true
you've contributed as well right
and i want you to ask your friend who
knows you knows your husband
for their honest reflection
and as you're talking i want you to be
honest with yourself about
do you want to stay married to this guy
or not
i'm a big believer that any marriage can
come around
if two people are willing to be humble
and lay down their nonsense
and work on coming together it sounds
like this one's got some
some deep crooked roots to it but it's
also got some real shallow roots that
are grown in other directions
and it feels like it's escalating right
from a shirt to a gun
to now a tractor and you're talking
anywhere from 20 to 60 to 100 000
depending what kind of farming you're
doing
and the reality is that's just a symptom
of two people who are
just roommates you're not intimate
anymore
you're not friends anymore now it's
becoming a tug of war
and so this is this is every bell should
be dinging
every every siren you have should be
going off
and before you just launch into him
because as you said your tendency is to
go at him i want you to get all those
feelings out of your head
and go through them with a friend and
decide which one of these are true which
one of these are not true
and i'm going to be honest with you i've
got a great marriage
and there have been seasons when if
somebody had asked me that question do
you want to stay married or not i would
have said no
right and that to me is a signal it's a
it's a it's a gong right it's a it's a
drum beat that says man
you're on shaky ground now and that's
when i had to stop what i was doing
lean way back into my marriage lean way
back into my relationship with my wife
and double down on healing and so far
every time we've been we've been over
that bridge
we've come out stronger on the other
side but it takes two people being very
humble
and all you can control in this
situation don is you
that's it and that sucks
but today get with somebody get all your
feelings out
mind them for truth right ask yourself
are they telling me the truth are they
not telling me the truth
and then i want you to sit down and come
up with a plan and then you're gonna
have to
make an arrangement with your husband
don't come at him but say this weekend
we need to talk about something that's
gonna take a couple hours i need you to
to clear your deck we need to have a
hard conversation
and if you come to the realization that
you don't want to be in this marriage
anymore you have to start the
conversation with that sentence
i'm afraid that i don't want to be in
this marriage anymore and i'm afraid you
don't either
i want to start from there if you do
want to save your marriage i want you to
start with that with that
that statement
we've been married for a long long time
13 years we have two beautiful kids
together we got a farm together
and we're roommates and i'm terrified
we're not going to make it if we don't
make some major changes
and you may have to go first with
talking about the stuff that you've
contributed to this thing
but this sucks and dawn is going to be
hard and i want you to lean directly
into it and here's the deal
after you have this conversation with
your friend after you do the hard work
of getting all your thoughts all those
jumbled frustrations out of your head
onto paper
after you have that conversation with
your husband and it's gonna be multiple
not just one it's gonna be multiple
i want you to give me a call back i want
you let me know how it goes i want you
to
walk with us everybody listening cause
you're not the only one there are
millions
of people in your situation right now
he just said out loud for the first time
i don't know if i want to be married
anymore
and that's a hard hard place to land
thank you so much for your vulnerability
thank you for trusting us with
being the first people that you've told
that to now the hard hard work begins
call your friend right now don and we
look forward to hearing back from you
all right let's go to noah in madison
wisconsin no what's up how are we doing
hey doing good john how are you
outstanding so how can i help brother
yeah so with kind of christmas time
coming up all the christmas parties
going on
um i guess my wife and i are kind of
curious on how to navigate
um hey hold on hold on one second you do
me a huge favor
yeah how old are you noah uh 25 25.
all right i'm gonna give you some world
advice that has nothing to do with why
you're calling is that cool
yes in the first sentence if you go back
and listen to this on the podcast you
said
the word kinda twice and i think sorta
or probably or something like that
like so with kind of christmas kind of
coming around and me and my wife kind of
work
i want you to be 25 year old freaking
noah
and start speaking with periods at the
end of your sentences the world needs
you okay
yes sir all right let's do it again here
we go alright here you go
all right so uh how do we navigate
christmas parties with christmas coming
around the corner with my
mom's side specifically uh who my wife
and i don't necessarily connect with all
that much
um so how do we kind of navigate or
excuse me how do you know there you go
good for you uh
navigate those parties um especially
when we can't really use
the the kovid uh scenario next year you
know do we bring that up with them i
guess i'm just looking for guidance on
what to do i love it man all right so no
this is a question that's gonna help
millions and millions of people so thank
you for having the courage to call and
ask
um there's so many folks going through
this so many folks navigated
thanksgiving
either well or poorly or sort of
right and
now you're in it and so thank you for
calling so let's do it i want to do a
mind experiment okay okay so
it's your mom's side of the family is
that right correct how long you've been
married
uh last july it's a year and a half oh
it's a year and a half you all
y'all are figuring this out as you go
right correct yeah
i love it traditions so your mom says
hey all of us are getting together
at such and such event and you say
we're not going to be able to make it
thank you so much for the invitation
hope you'll have an awesome time
period what's what's your mom's response
um so i mean wait
so we right before this uh phone calls
this weekend we did uh
we did message them we said hey you know
just with everything going on
uh we that was exactly what i actually
said you know hey thanks for the invite
hope you guys have a blast we're just
not going to make it this year
uh and this year you know what she said
okay you know sorry not to see you this
year but
we understand and it was you know
that it was an easy transition but
again kind of so do you feel weird about
saying that
i mean a little i guess the background
is growing up
you know we uh i felt obligated
to kind of go to the excuse me to go to
the uh party
yep um on my mom's side especially with
my dad's side
uh it's always a blast so never have any
issues there just with
especially my mom's it would always be
kind of the extended family so her
cousins her aunts and uncles like the
whole shebang
of recent years it's it's just her
immediate family so her sisters and then
my grandma
why don't you like go into why don't you
like going do they hug you and kiss you
and tell you how wonderful you are
talk politics like why don't you like to
go no
just i guess awkward
um besides those family christmases
i honestly never really hang out with my
mom's side you know never hanging out
um just out of out of that holiday
time but dig in to dig into awkward for
me
what does that mean it means you're just
standing there eating listening to
stories you've heard 30 times and
and being around a bunch of middle-aged
or older women what's awkward about it
yeah i guess with uh
i don't know um because here's the thing
if it's just awkward noah then go
like go it's an evening that you are
honoring your mom
and her family with and you're
25 you're going to bring joy to them
they're going to be excited to see you
you're the handsome little boy that made
well and here's his beautiful new wife
yeah it's boring life is boring right
it's awkward but if you if it's
something
put it this way if y'all just gonna sit
home and watch netflix and that's gonna
be more exciting
then forget that dude go if there's a
reason y'all aren't safe if they make
your wife feel uncomfortable
if it's just not as ex i mean go
right so you're not giving me you're not
selling me on why
why your mom and her family aren't worth
a few hours of your evening
yeah is it because it's just not
fun um
i g well with i guess the the
awkwardness behind it
it's not necessarily fun with us in the
sense that even with the extended family
one it was typically just my brothers
and i
uh just just uh at the table you know
talking with each other and kind of
saying hi you know for that few minutes
and then doing our own thing the rest of
the hour and a half two hours so i guess
that's kind of part of it
so no no listen i want you to do
something this year
if it's safe medically
i want you to go and i want you and your
wife to plan to ask
your mom questions her sister questions
so here's the thing you're showing up to
this event
really expecting to be entertained
and i want you to go
to be a participant go to be somebody
who isn't waiting to be plugged into but
who's plugging into other people
and my promise is those folks who are
there who are older than you who are
twice your age or 15 years older than
you or however old they are
have stories to tell that would blow
your mind have fun adventures to talk
about
if you can poke through man my
grandmother was as proper as propper
could be
but if you could get behind that proper
dude she was a riot
like she was the most sarcastic awesome
hilarious biting just a riot but she had
to get past it right
i want you to go and think of it this
way i'm going on behalf of my mom not
for me and dude you're talking like a
few
hours brother that's not a lot
i don't i i don't man when this call
started
i thought it was you weren't safe image
y'all feel uncomfortable
if it's just boring dude here because
they're gonna they're gonna not be
there they're gonna not be there someday
and i know you think it doesn't matter i
don't even think it it
i don't care that we don't talk that
much i'm telling you right now when it
comes to legacy it's going to matter
my wife is a qualitative researcher she
goes through stories
and letters and for the last few years
she's been
working on some uh several
books but these books are based on
letters that she's found and interviews
she's had with
90 year old 95 year old
members of her family she's tracked them
down she's met with them in strange
towns and little coffee shops and
nursing homes all across the united
states
and those boring quiet people who just
sit there in the corner at family events
have wild stories in her case
family members who were chased by nazis
in germany
and who had to figure out how to run a
dairy farm and had to figure out how to
survive the dust bowl
and who had to figure out how to how to
eat cows but they didn't know what they
were doing i mean i had to figure stuff
out
and you just get into those stories and
you find these love letters and you find
this richness in depth
my brother your family's not there to
entertain you your family's there to be
honored
to be with right and so if you're safe
if they're safe now again this is weird
because of covet
but if you're safe they're safe i want
you to go and i want you to you and your
wife to have fun
with coming up with questions that
you're going to ask what's the best
boyfriend you ever had
what was your first kiss what was the
weirdest date you ever went on
aunt whoever aunt karen aunt becky who
whoever they are hey grandma
what is your favorite boyfriend besides
grandad like right i want you to dig
into these questions
ask them what their favorite songs were
could they dance do they know who chubby
checkers was and do they love him right
get into it and my hope is you're going
to find out
a richness and depth to your family to
your legacy
here's the thing in and no this isn't
i'm not i'm not harping on you now
brother
we live in this culture where we burn
grandma's house down just because it was
old
it's a small 3-2 made out of old
hardwood
and we just burned it down because it's
too little and we throw up too tall and
skinnies they're going to last for about
25 years before they fall apart
so we can maximize the square footage of
that of that dirt
both presidential candidates were thrown
out because they were old
right that was the most common criticism
they both were whining
a lot and they were old a man sometimes
behind that
elder statesmanship is a lot of wisdom
they've seen a lot of things
i want to challenge all young people
listening to this if you're under the
age of 40
i want you to make it your mission in
life to surround yourself people who are
older than you
and not think about um is this
boring is this awkward
no man think about what you can glean
what kind of wisdom you can pick up
how you can be with folks and that might
mean getting around folks at your church
that might mean connecting with family
during the holidays and let's be super
honest this year
it may not happen kova is just screwing
up everything right
and elderly folks are in a very high
risk categories may not work
but man put yourself in those situations
so noah go do it
get around them um in fact i want you to
do it i want you to call me back and if
i was wrong i will announce to the whole
united
states and the world i was screwed up
and i was wrong no issue to stay at home
and then you'll find out and the next
year you'll be 26 your marriage will be
two and a half years old
and y'all will know we are never going
again and by the way
one more little ranty thing as we enter
into
the holiday season a couple of things
about
christmas number one if you don't want
to be around your family
don't use a virus as an excuse
have the courage to say we're not going
to make it this year
and let that be that because you're just
going to kick a can down the road and
it's not honorable
it's not honest if you can't go just say
i can't go right that's it
the second thing is this if you and your
girlfriend you and your boyfriend you
and your husband you and your
brother your sister y'all are planning
on going to whoever's house
for christmas you know you're going and
you know it's gonna be weird
you know uncle whoever is going to be
there you know that one uncle always
wants to pick you up with his thumbs
that one uncle
always wants to talk to you really close
with coffee breath
and whatever when you decide to go
all complaining is over it's over
because you know what's coming
decide once you decide you're in then
decide to go make it fun
as you possibly can go make it joyful
right now something about me that i like
is indoor plumbing i like it
for thanksgiving my family and i went to
my in-laws
hunting ranch in texas
there is no running water my
brother-in-law is awesome
you know what he did for us he dug us a
new hole
that's right he dug us a new hole and
they have this
old diner chair that they routered a
hole
out of it and they screwed down a toilet
seat onto a chair
and it sits over you guessed it the hole
so here's what i got to do as the in-law
of going to visit my family for
thanksgiving
once i decided i'm gonna go there's not
gonna be
any indoor plumbing we're gonna use the
bathroom instead whole
from that point forward i can't complain
about it
i can't whine about it i have to make it
the adventure that it is
and one day i will tell you about being
out there in the middle of the night and
hearing the wild
texas pigs coming right at me in the
middle of the night that's a whole other
conversation but all i'm saying is
once you decide to go whether it's no
plumbing whether it's no
weird uncles or whether it's weird
grandparents whatever it is
when you say you're in it's over it's
over
you're in don't whine about it don't be
frustrated about it
just go and make the absolute best of it
make it an adventure make it joyful
and then everyone around you their
spirits are lifted right and this is the
season for spirit lifting and god knows
we need it this year all right i'm done
i'm done being a looney tune about that
no thank you for that call brother
i want you and your wife to go i want to
hear what it's what how it goes let's go
to sydney in baton rouge sydney what is
happening
hey john thanks for having me on thank
you so much for calling how can i help
so i was looking for some i guess some
guidance or some advice on how to deal
with
not really having a social support
system
my husband and i moved in 2016 about two
hours away from all of our family
and due to various reasons between my
job not having a culture where you can
really make friends with your co-workers
because the level i was at
and um the dave ramsey journey that
we've been on and now the pandemic
i really just haven't had much
opportunity to make any
real-life friends and i'm sure you can
understand that some online friends are
good but they're not the same as having
someone to work for coffee
absolutely so
i number one thank you for this call
number two i'm living this
right now and sydney i could
be calling you and asking you this same
question
uh overhaul over the holidays over the
thanksgiving holidays um
went back we spent some of it at like i
said at my
in-laws ranch had an awesome time out
there and it was a blast
and then we went and spent some time
with my parents in other town where two
of my
oldest best accountability friends live
and kevin and michael and one night we
went and sat
together for golly dude i don't know
late into the next morning or early into
the next morning
and i tell you what sydney mike my soul
was
healed it felt good right and i realized
how much i missed my old friends
so i'm with you i moved to nashville a
few years ago i'm in the same boat here
are some things i'm
trying right now okay and all of this is
in beta all of this from still figuring
it out and all of this
the master word over all this is
intentionality okay
so a couple of things i've done number
one i know the science
and the science is what you're feeling
is
is worse than any sort of medical
pandemic we're having
i think loneliness is the chief enemy of
our time
right now and i think we have outsourced
all of our
friendships to clicks and thumbs and
interactions over screens and one of the
sayings i like to run around and say is
we've got four thousand friends on
facebook but we have no one to help us
move our couch
right i've got a hundred new likes on
instagram but i got nobody to help me
change a tire so i get to work on time
and we don't know our neighbors we don't
know our friends we don't even know our
church people anymore quite frankly we
don't know ourselves anymore
so all that to say is this here's a
couple of things i've done
i actually have had a couple of families
over to my house
that i had tangential tangential i don't
know how to say that word
i've had related um relationships with
i've known them
here and there sort of had them over to
my house
and they sat down at our kitchen table
me and my wife's kitchen table and i did
this so awkwardly
as i am good at doing i said hey
we'd like to ask you to be our friends
and here's what that means that means
that
we're gonna show up at games we're gonna
call you guys at 2am if we need
something
we're offering our services to you at
2am we're going to call you when we're
up we're going to call you when we're
down
but i had to say the word to another
grown couple we want to be your friend
one couple sydney laughed they're like
this is super weird
and the other couple the
the guy and he's become one of my close
friends and mentors
he got teary and he said nobody's ever
asked me that question before
which is a whole other conversation to
hold a statement on where we're at
that's number one number two my wife and
i have become hyper intentional about
having somebody out to our place
every single weekend period bar bar none
and some folks have come and they are
from high risk situations and so our
kids run around
in the front yard and we sit on the
front porch
and other times they don't care at all
and they've come into our house and then
i felt weird until we've all gone back
out to the front port
however we're making it work one of the
things that we're doing is being
intentional but the other thing we're
doing is being very gracious so wherever
people happen to be
on whatever health spectrum they are
whatever they believe about whatever
everybody's welcome to the house
and our main goal there is to pour into
other people be hospitable
and to be in connection with other
people
is that working all the time sydney no
is it
weird yeah it is is it awkward yeah
and sometimes it's really great at seven
o'clock this morning before the work day
i was in um communication with somebody
who's become a great friend of ours
here in nashville jp and beth and
they're coming over this weekend we're
just gonna hang out
and we're gonna have to be intentional
about it
i met them at church and i've met some
people at work some people
um you know just randomly but it is hard
intentional work
the other thing i'll tell you this
sydney is stay plugged in however you
can to your old friends
whether that's email whether that's
phone calls whether that's it's not
enough it's not as good
but it it is a it is just
a drop of cold water in the desert until
this thing's over and we can start
connecting again
so when i tell you those things how does
that rattle around in your head
well i i really wish i could do some of
those things
but what's holding you back
um all for one we don't really have a
space
or in a tiny apartment okay
um we did used to have some people over
but
they've kind of all like gone off onto
their own lives
since then and stopped really talking to
us are they and we can't really keep
reaching out to people who don't reach
back
yeah so what i'm going gonna tell you
sydney and i can hear it in your voice
is hard and loneliness sucks
what i'm gonna tell you is you're gonna
have to keep trying
you're gonna have to keep trying and if
that means you gotta go meet out at a
park if you all have to go meet someone
in public space
if you've got friends that you know are
safe and they are well
and you don't mind having them inside
your apartment then so be it
but you've got to keep trying okay so i
want you to think of this
like eating healthy only way more
important
i want you to think of this like taking
your medication but way more important
and i know it feels like rejection when
they don't call you back it feels like
rejection when they don't invite you
i know it does but you got to keep
leaning into it
because loneliness will dissolve you
loneliness will dissolve your marriage
it gets heavier and heavier okay
okay is your husband on board with this
yeah he's actually like the only person
i see most of the time
sure are you working on that are you
working
i'm working from home right now okay
and are you are you at a level in your
company where
it doesn't make sense to have a bunch of
friends because it's just
awkward because of roles and reporting
structures and things
well i tried um like getting to know
some of my co-workers before everybody
went to work from home but i just joined
the company in september
and then we had a big launch in january
so everybody was busy focused on that
and then i kind of started being like a
little more casual with some of my
co-workers and then the pandemic hit and
everybody went home
gotcha so
i want you to be hyper intentional and
this is going to sound ridiculous
but it's where we're at right now and
i'm in the same boat as you
i want you to start putting this on your
calendar okay
i want you to put on your calendar i'm
going to reach out to one person
every day and check in see how they're
doing if possible and talk to him on the
phone even if it's for 10 minutes or 15
minutes
i want you to set up like hey let's have
a drink out at the
at the clubhouse here at the apartment
complex i want to meet you at a park
let's get together for sandwiches
my friend stephanie she's a professor in
texas she's been meeting with students
on her front porch
it's the best they can do and she said
it has been magic for the students it's
been magic for her
whatever it is find a way what you
cannot do
is just fold it up and give up and i
know it feels personal i know it feels
hard
i know it feels like friendship
shouldn't be this challenging you're
right they shouldn't be that's the
season we're in and it sucks
but i can tell you this if you give up
and you fold up you're going to
really put a lot of pressure on yourself
you're going to put a lot of pressure on
your husband
and it's going to be really difficult
for both of you to cycle your way out of
this
so you be intentional you go first i
guarantee you have something to offer to
people sydney i know you do
i know you and your and your husband as
a couple have something to offer to
people
my guess is you are fun my guess is
you're hilarious my guess is you have
all kinds of things to offer folks
you just got to keep trying to keep
trying
i'm with you i'm living this with you
sydney i want you to give it a shot for
a few weeks
and if it totally tanks call me back if
it is a disaster call me back but i want
you to have given it i want you to have
called somebody
every day for the next couple of weeks i
want you to put yourself
way out there meet for lunches in the
park for early dinners and drinks at a
clubhouse or a friend's will come over
to your apartment
so be it don't give up on yourself
sydney you're worth friends you're worth
connecting with
all right so as we wrap up the show
james this one's a little bit long so
don't crank the music too soon
because this one's for real i heard this
this morning at my house
on a record sitting with my kids
and i got teary my daughter said daddy
why are you crying and i said
honey some songs are so beautiful
they're transcendent
and they get into your dna a little bit
i didn't remember this song being there
but it is
it's from the 1987 joshua tree record
you two and they're classic i still
haven't found what i'm looking for
and bono writes i've climbed highest
mountains and i've run through the
fields
only to be with you and i've run
i have crawled i've scaled these city
walls
only to be with you but i still haven't
found what i'm looking for
i have kissed honeyed lips felt the
healing in her fingertips and it burned
like
fire this burning desire i've spoke with
the tongues of angels
i've held the hand of a devil it was
warm in the night and i was cold as a
stone but i
still haven't found what i'm looking for
i believe in the kingdom come then all
the colors will bleed into
one so yes i'm still running
you broke the bonds and you lose the
change you carried the cross of my shame
you know i believed it
but i still haven't found what i'm
looking for
hang in there folks you're worth not
being lonely you're worth connecting
this is the dr john dolone show